we are a little more than 12 hours away
from President Trump and North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un meeting for the
first time Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said this morning that complete
denuclearization is the only outcome the
US will accept Kim and the president are
both in Singapore ahead of the
high-stakes meeting this is the first
time that a sitting US president will
meet with a leader of North Korea the
summit will take place at the capela
hotel on sentosa island a high-end
resort CBS Evening News anchor Jeff Glor
is leading our coverage from Singapore
Jeff good morning Nora good morning to
you on the eve of this summit an
extraordinary moment for this city-state
here in Singapore and extraordinary
moments in the diplomatic histories of
both of these countries after months
last year of lobbing insults and threats
at each other from nearly 7,000 miles
away President Trump and kim jungeun are
staying in hotels less than half a mile
apart both leaders say they hope for
peace and normalized relations between
these two nations major Garrett he is
here with us now in the Trump
administration's plans for the summit
major you just left a briefing with the
Secretary of State yeah we'll get to
that in a minute Jeff good morning
everyone the summit will begin as we
might all expect with a handshake talk
about a photo-op and then possibly as
many as two hours of direct
conversations president Trump kim
jungeun only there translators present
now just a little while ago the
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said the
United States will maintain economic
pressure on the north until it takes
verified steps to dismantle its nuclear
arsenal but Pompeo also said the u.s. is
prepared to offer the north something
brand new
as cameras frantically and noisily
captured this relatively mundane moment
thank you very much president Trump
stood with his Singapore host prime
minister lee sin long and sounded upbeat
about the coming main event the historic
summit with North Korean dictator Kim
Jong hoon
after the working lunch mr. Trump was
presented with a birthday cake in
advance of his 72nd birthday on Thursday
[Applause]
every meeting and movement no matter how
small was fodder for more than 3000
journalists this is truly a mission of
peace Secretary of State Mike Pompeo the
president's point man spent part of the
day with North Korean officials laying
the groundwork for direct talks between
the President and Kim
Pompeyo said the u.s. was prepared to
offer new security guarantees to the
north but offered no specifics under the
umbrella of security assurances would
that include removing US forces now in
South Korea we're prepared to take what
will be secured assurances that are
different unique than have been provided
that America has been willing to provide
previously we think this is both
necessary and appropriate before leaving
the g7 economic meeting for Singapore
the president was asked how quickly he
would know if Kim was serious about the
summit's principle goal denuclearization
I think within the first minute I'll
know I just might touch my feel that's
why that's what I do
duyan Kim of the Korean Peninsula future
forum call that approach risky and
dangerous Kim jong-un is going to play
the long game
and so Trump really has his work cut out
for him he cannot determine the fate of
North Korea the fate of the Korean
Peninsula in just one minute
the future of US forces in South Korea
looms large over this summit Pompeyo
would not rule out reducing the current
23,000 soldier footprint the US has in
South Korea just moments ago the
president spoke by telephone with South
Korean president moon jae-in touching
base one last time before the hue storix
stomach and possible deal making begins
Jeff all right major thank you very much